you ever heard the phrase zombie
companies let me explain to you what
zombie companies are these are companies
that are making enough money to pay
their bills pay their debt payments but
not enough to invest into growth in
other words these are companies that
should be going out of business they're
hanging on to somebody else's market
share that this other company could do a
better job in by the way why are they
still around because today according to
Bloomberg Total return index 18% of
companies are part of zombie companies
today barely making it some big names
you need to know about you know what it
was in 1997 only 1% we went from 1% in
1997 that's 25 26 years ago to 18%
that's an increase of
1700% growth in companies that don't
make money barely pay their bills don't
reinvest why are they still around we're
going to talk about that today and why
you should know about that
today okay so if you get value out of
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel so the whole
concept of zombie companies was started
in Japan called a lost decade this
concept originated in Japan during the
90s following the collapse of the
country's asset price bubble these
companies were characterized by heavy
Reliance on Bank financing to remain
operational meaning if I don't get any
loan I can't meet my expenses I'm going
out of business number two inefficiency
and poor performance number three
inability to generate sufficient
earnings to cover operating costs and
debt obligations now now here's a kicker
the cause the reason for so many zombie
companies was attributed to forbearance
by banks that are unwilling to let
borrowers fail you know this whole
concept of too big to fail they're like
no no no no no we can't let them fail
because it's like the drug dealer
doesn't want to get the atct so addicted
to drugs that he kills himself so he
comes back buying drugs they're so
addicted to debt that you don't want to
kind of let him go out of business
because they're still making a payments
does that kind of make sense guys are
getting paid the commission not
necessarily good for economy by the way
but that's what's happening government
policies aimed at preserving employment
and social stability and economists argu
that the survival of zombie companies
hindered economic recovery resources
were diverted from productive firms to
support alien companies let me get this
straight you got five companies three of
them are doing a good job these two guys
are doing a [__] job we give them money
to keep performing at D level standards
rather than give this market share to
these guys or let a new company come and
disrupt these guys no no no let's keep
giving these guys money why can you
imagine how ludicrous that is as like an
NBA coach letting a player keep playing
and he's shooting three for 20 but you
keep giving him the shots why would
anybody in the right mind do that that's
what these banks are doing and
Innovation and productivity were stifled
by the protection of inefficient firms
so what happened in 2008 this is when
zombie companies became famous and
popular in the US because of this
program called tarp which most people
don't know what tarp stands for most of
us know what tarp is but tarp stands for
you ready they're just telling us what
tarp is troubled asset relief program
this is like a person who can't pay
their credit card payment they're like
let's keep giving them more credit cards
because he's going to keep making credit
but his debt keeps getting bigger why
are we doing that because let's destroy
him because he's going to be a slave to
credit card companies and Visa just had
record-breaking profits because interest
rates today are at the highest they've
ever been in credit card company so
imagine if credit card company like dude
let people keep making these interest
payments this is awesome except imagine
you're doing that to multi-billion auto
companies they're slaves to this debt
that they own to the slave owner which
is a debt holder if you read scripture
you know what it says to the person that
owns the debt they own the other
individual these companies are owned by
the debt holder you know what's crazy
with this whole concept of zombie
companies you know how many people are
going to be zombies and they don't even
know they're individuals they're working
at a company they don't know what's
going on they're casual they haven't
read a book for a while they're not even
doing their business planning boom
they're going to lose their position
somebody newer and hunger is going to
come and take their position away from
them same thing applies within
corporations and companies some people
are going to go into the new year 2024
they had a great 2023 they got money in
the bank but they're not paranoid
they're not looking they're not planning
they're not preparing they're the same
person they go into 24 being the the
same person all of a sudden Boom the
market kicks their tail this is why I
wrote this book called choose your
enemies wisely business planning for the
audacious field we have put a few years
thousands of hours into this book comes
out December 5th if you want 2024 to be
the beginning of the greatest years of
your life go order the book choose your
enemies wisely click on the link below
highly recommend you also order the
audible so I tell some stories in
audible that's not written in the book
and make 2024 the beginning of the
greatest years of your life the term
zombie company resurfaced in context of
the US financial crisis of 2008
government bailouts particularly through
the $700 billion troubled asset relief
program were criticized for rescuing
failing financial institutions critics
argue that bailouts perpetuated the
existence of zombie companies government
support prevented Market forces from
weeding out poorly performing firms
taxpayers money your money my money was
used to propep up businesses that were
unlikely to recover the impact of zombie
companies on the US economy is debated
some argue that their presence hinders
economic growth and innovation others
maintain that zombie companies provide
employment and contribute to economic
stability which means let's keep low
standards as long as people got jobs who
cares let's maintain low standards
rather than increasing the expectation
for companies to say stop making so many
dumb decisions stop making so many
decisions that are bad for the investors
make better decisions if you don't let's
give you the market share to somebody
else that's making better decisions by
the way if that company goes out of
business and they got 10,000 employees
what do you think those 10,000 employees
are going to go to to the other seven
competitors they're going to go get a
job elsewhere because that market share
of customers is going somewhere so the
risk isn't on the employee the risk is
on the employeer are not doing a good
job with the money that they have so now
watch this in 2021 Goldman Sachs
reported that some 133% of us listed
companies could be considered zombies
this is just two years ago which it
called firms that haven't produced
enough profit to service their
debt you haven't produced enough profits
to service your debts bringing to you
you you haven't made enough income to
pay off your debt if you don't pay off
your debt what comes next bankruptcy if
you're an individual or decrease your
lifestyle but not if you're running a
corporation there is give them more debt
to service the debt that they already
couldn't have let me just continue
reading this because this makes no sense
to me and I'm sure it doesn't make sense
to you either the Federal Reserve study
found that roughly 10% of public firms
were zombie companies in 2019 public
firms on the stock market one out of
every 10 company on the stock market is
a zomb company this is preo when the
economy was doing actually good finally
a deutche bank study by Jim Reed in 2021
found you ready that over
25% of us companies were zombies in 2020
and according to the IMF this number was
only 1% in 1997 how in the hell did this
happen low interest rate money being
given away to people that money was so
cheap and they kept paying all the stuff
that they were paying off and all of a
sudden now the rates being high they're
sitting there saying what the hell are
we going to do now what are the ways
government going to bail us out now you
know how they're going to sleep today
they have no clue what they're going to
do but you know why they're probably
sleeping like a little baby because they
know Daddy's going to come and build
them out and you know who daddy is me
and you who fought for these people we
vote for and we give away billions of
dollars to these companies to not go out
of business because poor these companies
that made some bad choices and God
forbid somebody like an Elam mus will
come out and piss them off and do
something better go [__]
yourself is that clear hey Bob and no
what a bad guy he is let us keep going
golfing three four times a week shame on
you Elon Musk for being a little too
driven and taking market share away from
us you don't deserve that we do because
we went to the right schools and you did
not are you freaking kidding me you know
what that sounds like a little baby
crying but that's exactly what's going
on with these guys so let me give you
some zombie companies and you're going
to be like well I probably don't
recognize these zombie companies you
ready here's five of them for you Sears
Holdings Corporation once a retail giant
seers face significant financial
struggles and was often classified as a
zombie company due to its mounting debts
and declining sales the company filed
for bankruptcy in 2018 by the way that's
what should happen breaks my heart
because the founders work their asses
off to build this company that's been
around for God knows how long but the
people running the company today
destroyed it and guess what that's okay
that's exactly what should happen to
them as it's a funeral for a company but
the existing leaders that were hired by
the board were not the right lead ERS
and they caused a legendary company like
this to go out of business number two JC
Penney this American department store
chain fac similar challenges to sear
struggling with large debts and failing
to adapt to changing retail Trends JC
Penney was also often labeled as a
zombie company before filing bankruptcy
in 2020 number three Toys R Us the toy
retailer struggled with large debt load
making it difficult to invest in stores
and online sales it was considered a
zombie company before declaring
bankruptcy in 2017 iHeart media Inc the
largest radio station owner in the
United States iHeart media faced
significant challenges and was often
referred to as a zombie company it filed
for bankruptcy in 2018 to restructure
its massive debt load GE massive company
took a lot of money from the government
didn't therefore for period G was also
considered a zombie company due to its
high level of debt and struggling
business units however it has since
taken steps to restructure and reduce
its debt and by the way keep in mind
some of these companies the the the
financial situation can't change for
them AIG got 1813 billion from the US
government us and Bob and mosha ended up
paying that back with a CFO David Herzog
some 2 $ billion in interest they paid
it back within a few years I was there
when this happened had dinner with the
CFO one time in 2012 or 13 in Chicago at
Ritz Carlton while they were going
through this 2011 or 12 so in some cases
it did work but not in all cases if in
one or two cases out of 30 cases it
works should we keep doing it if in nine
out of 10 cases at work should we do it
yes but if it's 2 and seven should we if
it's 2 and 10 should we no let
capitalism do its part and see what
takes place but no they're not letting
that happen that's why we're at 25% of
zombie companies according to Deutsche
Bank Jim Reed so I want to show you a
couple charts if you take a look at this
one here this is a share of us zombie
firms from 2015 to 2020 okay the red is
listed on the stock market the gray is
private if you look at this 2015 2016
2017 all of them keep going up why
because the rates have been kept at 0%
nearly at 0% for God knows how many
years nearly eight years then when 2017
comes around what does Trump do in 2016
2017 they start increasing rates because
we can't be at 0 to 1% this entire time
so go back to the Chart now the list is
and private what happens to them notice
the zombie companies decrease the next 3
years 2017 drops 2018 drops 2019 drops
and by the way you know the companies I
just listed you know when toys Russ went
out of business in 2017 you know when JC
Penney went out of business 2020 you
know when Sears filed bankruptcy 2018
you know when iHeart filed bankruptcy
2018 why cuz the rate started going up
and they're like wait a minute we can't
keep borrowing money we better get our
act together the Cor ation between these
two tells a story but by the way Ju Just
to be straight up here the president
Trump wasn't for POW increasing the
rates even though he put Powell in there
for the FED aare Powell raised it
because he felt that's exactly what was
needed so watch this neither president
Trump nor President Biden has been happy
with what Powell has been doing that's
why Powell is actually a good Fed chair
because he's doing whatever he can to
help the economy it's not an easy job
but to me we got to keep increasing
rates because if we keep them low the we
are lots of these zombie companies are
going to be everywhere it's going to be
a lot of fake success some of this fake
success got to be exposed by the rates
going higher through the pruning process
that we got to go through that we
haven't for a while so this next part
it's going to be a little bit technical
but I'm going to try to explain it to
you I think you need to know this part
because there is a format to find out
who is two years away from going out of
business there's actually a formula for
it when you look at this to current
zombie companies based on Federal
Reserve parameters the average numbers
around $374 million and has a net
negative return of 3.4% on the asset so
there's a few things when they look at
this it's called the icr one of them the
interest coverage ratio is calculated by
dividing the earnings before interest
and tax ebit not ebita by the total
amount of interest expense on all of the
company's outstanding debts the second
one is the debt ratio which is the debt
ratio is fundamental analysis measure
that looks the extent of company's
leverage and then you have compound
annual growth rate called ker all right
so the question becomes as an investor
can you kind of go out there and find
out what company is about to be on this
list that is potentially a zombie
company there's actually a formula for
it a couple people came out with a
theory one of them is called the Olen
model which predicts bankruptcy risk
using a multiactor financial algorithm
developed by Dr James Olsson in 1980 any
percentage value above 50% indicate the
risk of a firm's bankruptcy within two
years and the second model is the
Ultimate model used to predict whether a
firm is likely to go into bankruptcy
within two years and uses many variables
from the income and balance sheet for
the analysis distress is considered high
with a value below 181 so if you want to
go a little bit more into technical
details of it we'll put the link below
but I just kind of want to show you some
of these companies when you look at this
they graded from the highest to low
these are some of the companies that are
on the verge of filing bankruptcy look
at the names on this list you may
recognize AMC look at the score .85 on
the Alman Z score it's got the Aon score
there as well the other one is Virgin
Galactic how about Lionsgate
entertainment what about Norwegian
Cruise Line This is the formula they're
coming up with to say there's a very
high likelihood these guys are about to
go out of business ins SP the way bed
bath and beond another great example
there they stood out as one of the most
investors should stay away from some of
the biggest problems included Share
value that they have been falling
steadily for nearly a decade location in
or near malls which have not performed
well for several years desperate
attempts to lower overhead by closing
about 200 retail stores negative
operation profits more than 4 billion in
debt increase competition from smaller
and online Sellers and by the way you
don't have to be an accountant or CPA
certification to understand this part
just look at this here bit bath and
beond on from 2010 year-over-year
quarterly growth you see the green green
is good red is bad good numbers 2010
still good numbers 11 12 is still good
numbers 13 gets a little scary 14 shows
up 15 a little bit of profits and then
the red keeps getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger would
you invest into this company check this
out Bed Bath and Beyond had a chance to
turn itself around when Mark Triton
became Co in November of 2020
unfortunately for the store and its
shareholders the covid-19 pandemic
ruined those plans Bed Bath and Beyond
could survive right now though it has
the homework of being a zombie company
doing its best to pretend it can still
live a normal life by the way I don't
want to overwhelm you with a ton of
different story I can give you a lot of
stories some say Uber may be a zombie
company even though when you look at
Uber's numbers here they're operating
income uh over the years 2019 2020 2021
it's been in the negative for a while
this the first time they've had
back-to-back quarters where they
actually starting to make some money
right but that could be one where hey
like Amazon used to say don't invest
into Amazon if you're not with us for
the long run because you're not going to
make money I'm reinvesting everything
and I'm boom guess what he didn't make
profits for a long time then he was
right so that may be the case with Uber
another example could be for some are
calling Fort a zombie company because
they've had three years of sales growth
being under 3% but the government just
gave them $9.2 billion to bail out so
guess what now all of a sudden their
numbers are looking good the debt made
them look good but without debt they
were constantly and now you're going to
be e now you're going to be the next
Tesla who knows but the reality is some
of these companies are big companies
that are zombie companies and Ford could
be one of them so if you got value out
of this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel the one thing I
will tell you is if you got value out of
this video I did another video that is
on the Consulting industry and how some
people became so successful they stopped
asking other people what's a better way
of doing it they stopped learning they
just kind of got well we've been doing
it here for 20 30 years what we're going
to be doing boom went out of business no
Market's changing things are changing
the other day we have a guy that's
cutting clips for us and we're paying
this guy 20 bucks a clip 10 bucks a clip
okay we'll do this for you now ai you
literally upload a three-hour video and
this three-hour video the AI picks the
top 20 best Reals in it puts the video
cuts it creative adds the captions adds
the description you don't do any of it
that's AI disrupting the entire industry
but those who are not looking that way
all of a sudden boom somebody new comes
in takes that market share away from
them so if you've not watched the video
on Consulting highly recommend you watch
that video take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye